hello and welcome to so you play taxi
and taxi in Finland and this is a
disciple of Hong a ya b3 all over all
over again I really don't know Karen
horney is playing as every game I don't
we don't know about mr. Peck see here
but I really don't understand why people
play that opening I mean at least I
don't understand why they play it on
regular basis now and then okay but our
friend from spain is playing it every
game absolutely every game okay what
about this year who before is weak how
is that how did that happen I wonder
ever made some mistake there hmm it
looks a bit strange don't see how to
defend he for here hmm very weird
it should be for consumer now I probably
have to do that and then see if I can
get some compensation out of this very
weird I don't know what I did wrong it
was a normal line maybe it was a six
wrong and wrong timing or anything
I don't know so let's see can we get
some kind of compensation all of this of
course not all that was planned or but
ok maybe I get some activity going here
f3 can I take on e3 there is that
possible I think it is takes only three
and you probably can just recapture you
can just read capture
ok
here you can just recapture
may have to check that opening again
from the a6 was really wrong in this
kind of thing yeah it's difficult to
hold this or is it Bishop t6 I don't
know anyway he went a threesome Jim well
this is not enough compensation but but
it's enough to to still have some hope
that that's for sure it's kind of active
again an active still should be six can
be an option or rook lift would be cool
I cookie 86 h8 h 6 knots not so easy to
play for white disposition ok I think I
need all the pieces here anyway so
hi this is getting interesting mmm
question is no it's no question this one
probably Queenie one though okay 21 i
can take and takes it to AI mean okay i
don't i would like to check Nathan but
ok let's start with this
can both make sense actually let's do
this it's not threatening that much
actually Bishop takes pawn takes a is a
so depending
rook f5 who aged 5 and like the the
monster rook lift why not don't quite
see what is that I don't see a big big
drawback maybe shooting air yes to has
to give some checks down here i can go
gauge 5 and but then when you can
probably probably a perpetual me then
check can you do more i don't think it
can
okay i don't think i have anything
better check night you [ __ ] I can go 95
m ah I thought cream cakes but F takes
is a check this is China that's that's
bad that's bad I saw that but I didn't
see that after Queen takes checks as a
check this is the thing Wow
Jim okay black resign it's a bit of a
shame I actually think that I had
excellent compensation for the porn
probably more than enough compensation
at some point pretty sure about that
around here this shouldn't be good for
white okay the computer says equal
rights its enormous pressure I think
this is this made sense I think probably
there were alternatives I can also take
with the rook maybe this is better the
engine wants to do that it gives us is
equal the whole thing age six and g5 is
also interesting now yeah okay this is
not working and because of 95 so I have
to have to do something else look at 48
is still roughly equal and I mean I just
have enough strategic compensation for
that so it's not a big deal than ever
porn down hmm what I wonder is though I
want to quickly check the opening I made
a video that but i already have
forgotten the details I know h5 is the
chemo hat each 5h for our Kim this is I
forgot about that and this is the thing
I can I can do this actually I know fh
for hmm this is this is really nice foot
black actually so i forgot this in ok
Bishop e7 that that was now kind of yeah
patio I got some compensation but it
wasn't intended at all
hmm yeah tough but next time I should go
h5 that was a bit of a Miss down in the
opening that got me into some some
trouble that should shouldn't be okay
thanks for watching